the next movie is me sending a picture
of me sucking my lips and I go got any
picks not the lip biting and he sends me
a picture he's driving and I would
obviously respond with eyes on the road
buddy
you're [__] dude sorry man it was the
lip biting for me sorry I'm a goof
y oh thank you made my day that's pretty
good seriously I don't know how you walk
around with [__] in your body
I don't even know what that means what
kind of line is that and then I respond
with It's a cruel life
a guy like you should be on empty all
day every day and very sleepy oh that
would be a dream and then I send him a
picture of me sleeping like this
oh cause you just nodded bro this guy
sent me a dick pic